dans les rues de la havane la tristesse
et l'abattement sont palpables
la nouvelle vient d'être annoncée à la
télévision cubaine
irma a provoqué plusieurs décès dans le
pays après le passage du dangereux ou
encore i en main sur le territoire
national nous avons recensé pour
l'instant la terrible perte de 10
personnes dans les provinces de la
havane baetens à camagüey et ciego de
avila
l'ouragan qui pourtant n'a fait que
frôler cuba à semer partout la
désolation
malgré une anticipation et une
préparation exemplaire
les habitants n'ont pu sauver grand
chose pour certains aujourd'hui les
pertes sont considérables
nous n'avons plus rien nous avons tous
perdu le réfrigérateur la machine à
laver tout aux personnes n'avaient
jamais vu le malecon dans cet état avec
ses impressionnantes vagues de 10 mètres
la mer a pénétré loin très loin à
l'intérieur de la ville rend dans la
capitale méconnaissable c'est une très
grande catastrophe ma maison mon
commerce tout est détruit
je suis un entrepreneur privé j'ai
essayé de sauver tout ce que j'ai pu
mais le nom est monté trop vite
c'était terrible la maison les meubles
maintenant il faut attendre que l'eau se
retire pour tout mettre à sécher
montréal le réseau téléphonique a tenu
le coup mais il n'y a plus d'eau
courante plus d'électricité et herman a
détruit beaucoup de stocks de nourriture
cuba s'apprête à vivre un après ouragan
très difficile